Turning 60 in a few weeks and wrestling with everyone needs a colonoscopy at age 55 or older.
I had a PET CT scan three years ago when that have showed any issues.
What are your thoughts on these things?
Well, we've had patients that have discovered colon cancer via a colonoscopy.
And so it's hard for me to knock colonoscopies.
In the same sense, I've never had a colonoscopy and I don't plan on ever getting a colonoscopy.
But I'm not saying you should do as I do.
There's pros and cons to a colonoscopy.
So just like any medical procedure, this is not a non-invasive one, obviously.
So, yeah, I mean, especially if you've had a PET scan and CT scan three years ago,
it certainly would decrease the need for a colonoscopy.
No, because, yeah, I mean, one could argue that, well, that is just, you know,
what if you have polyps growing now that could be plucked out that could be precancerous?
Yeah, you could make that argument.
So, yeah, it's hard for me to knock doing a colonoscopy.
What it is, you know, kind of the only preventative procedure that medicine really does.
But in the same sense, you know, people have had issues with them too.
Or can I just get a cologuard test?
A cologuard test is actually the same technology for those who have been with me for, you know, five plus years.
We had the IBG test.
So, the IBG test uses the cologuard test, I should say, uses the exact same technology as the IBG test there.
Literally, the exact same technology.
IBG went the way of trying to sell it to practitioners that would, you know, that were, you know, trying to do preventative care and cancer care.
Um, cologuard went the way of selling out to a pharmaceutical company that then got an approved for insurance function.
So, um, in cologards to the round.
So, we'll figure people that want to pay cash for the test.
So, I don't know if they will do cologuard.
If you had it, you had two diagnosed the past, um, because it could throw that off.
And if you still have cancer elsewhere or something, but you can certainly check into that.